hi I'm Nick Gillespie for Reason TV
today we're talking with mikela Rong
author of it's our turn to eat the story
of a Kenyan whistleblower who is the
Kenyan whistleblower and what is his
story
the Kenyan whistleblower is John
Githongo who was an old friend of mine
when in 2003 a new president came into
Kenya swearing that he was gonna clean
out the corruption of the Moy era he
appointed this man as his
anti-corruption chief and what happened
was that John discovered a whole new
scandal called Anglo leasing and also
discovered that all his closest
colleagues all his ministers and
government that he worked most closely
with were involved in that so then he
faced this predicament do I do I tell
all or do I keep it to myself and so
that's what the books about
and what did he decide to do and how did
it play out he eventually decided to go
public and he was an extraordinary
position because he had taken this
precaution of taping his conversation
over the years with with these
ministerial colleagues who were saying
to him openly
you know this scandal is us you know
it's it's it's it's your own ethnic
group behind us so he had all this
material which I think is unprecedented
in Africa probably in in most countries
so he compiled the dossier eventually
leaked it to the press and that's
essentially the story and seeing the
fallout because on the one hand there
were a few people who stepped aside who
were asked to leave office but
essentially nobody ended up returning
the money
nobody was prosecuted and one of the
things I try and pull out in my in my
book is that I think the donor community
in Kenya and often in Africa has proved
to be very very lacks and very
complacent about these kind of
corruption scandals that go to the heart
of MIS governance in Africa so in the
wake of everybody acknowledging that
corruption is rampant that it had
survived the Moore regime there was
really no change then there was lip
service paid
in fact I believe that the businessman
who went to the new ministers and said
here's a great way of making money here
all these da G's security and military
contracts were almost certainly people
who had dealt with the previous regime
so there was a very smooth continuance
and I think what happened was that a
rather naive and wishful thinking donor
community which desperately wanted to
start lending money which it had frozen
off undermine it wanted to keep to start
up the money again to the kavacha regime
they really didn't want to see the
evidence of their own eyes what is the
larger significance of this Kenyan story
I mean everybody recognizes that if you
have a corrupt government or a corrupt
regime you really can't do economic
development you can't really have
political freedom or political stability
how does the Kenyan story translate to a
larger story about Africa or about the
developing world generally well I would
disagree with you I don't think everyone
does recognize the things you said they
should but they don't and I think what
we've seen in the last few years in
Africa is the sort of Jeffrey Sachs
school of thought which is about putting
the emphasis on more and more aid to get
countries out of the poverty trap and
sort of downplaying the politics and
behaving as though local politics which
are very poisonous in places like Kenyan
and very ethnic are irrelevant and you
can help a country despite those
politics and I think what the Kenyan
case showed and it's true of many
African countries is you cannot pretend
to help a country if you don't cast a
very critical eye on the politics of the
day and if you have a government that's
busy stealing you know there is no point
continuing to spout the sermon about
helping and aid and rolling out the
World Bank projects and the IMF so I
mean yours squarely against the kind of
post-war development model which is that
you have organizations like the World
Bank or the International Monetary Fund
which just says there is a huge amount
of money we're helping you this is we
call this development and here's a bunch
of money that you could be you know then
government States officials at every
level just spend whatever
where they want I'm not of the dambisa
Moyo school of thought the author of
dead 8 who sort of says it's all rubbish
cut it off five years and that should be
the end of it but I do think that we
massively overemphasize and over play
the role that aids is going to play in
in these African countries future it
isn't as important as we like to think
it can do more harm than good
it certainly did I think in Kenya you
can undermine people like John Githongo
so what's the best thing that the West
can do to help Africa become a richer
freer place I think at the end of the
day it's not going to be in Western
hands and that's something that we need
to recognize and something we haven't
wanted to recognize with all this
emphasis on on upping aid we can save
lives in terms of malarial bednets
treatment for HIV we can prevent people
from starving we cannot make an African
Administration or do the right thing
and most of the key developments in
Africa the most encouraging ones have
come from the private sector in Africa
can you talk a little bit about them and
I think there are several examples are
routinely quoted the spread of the
internet across Africa the the role of
the mobile phone in terms of linking
people up making them more aware the
spread of the private radio station
spreading the word about governance
democracy anti-corruption these are the
really important factors and actually
these are things that have happened
without that much explain the title of
your book it's our turn to eat what does
that mean it's the phrase you hear a lot
in Kenya you also hear it a lot around
Africa and it's basically about one
ethnic community usually a minority
ethnic community saying if we have our
guy in state house in the presidency
it'll be our communities turn to eat so
he'll take care of us you'll make sure
that contracts go to our group he'll
make sure our constituents who gets the
development money he'll make sure that
it's jobs for the boys your two previous
books were in the footsteps of mr. Kurtz
living on the brink of disaster in the
Congo
and I didn't do it for you how the world
betrayed a small African nation and
you're talking about Eritrea there why
are you interested in Africa I started
working there as a Reuters correspondent
and it just slowly I became de facto
expert and it really has been a
professional interest it's not an
emotional interest so you're not going
to buy a coffee plantation I don't have
a family links and I also I sort of
slightly disliked the sentimentalism you
meet people and they say oh Africa gets
into your blood and you kind of think I
find it a fascinating continent I've got
to know very many different countries
you know each one radically different
from each other it's intellectually
intriguing it's incredibly rich and
diverse but I do slightly rebel against
that idea that you you you fall in love
with a place and then in some way that
kind of blinds you to it it's just the
place that I haven't have worked what
you know in in the post-colonial your
Asia for the most part South American
large part so let's even say Australia
and New Zealand have come a long way
they're almost civilized now but Africa
continues to lag behind in terms of
overall gross domestic product things
like that is it I mean ours or you know
indicators life expectancy is going down
in many African countries what I mean is
there any hope for Africa I mean you
have to look at the history the Cold War
only entered in 89 so when we tend to
lecture African countries about you know
why is it taking so long you said I
think the the area in which the west and
the Soviet Union and China were
interfering in incredibly damaging ways
and manipulating the local political
systems and leaders and and with utter
cynicism is only over since 89 I mean
that is so recent and then you have to
think before then you have the colonial
period the nation-state being very fresh
and before that slavery devastating the
continent so I think you know
these are unique combination of factors
and what you're seeing now is this new
generation coming up who are highly
educated very urban
they are the Gyeonggi fungo generation
they're people who look at their
continent in a different way who are at
ease in this cosmopolitan world we all
live in and I think they are going to
change this continent what is your next
project um I'm actually thinking of
writing a novel when John turned up on
my flat and went into hiding at my place
at the start of this whole story I was
actually writing a novel and I would
like to go back and finish it
what's the novel about okay I just hope
it's not about how Africa like herpes is
in your blood all right well very good
thank you
Michela wrong for talking to us today
author most recently of it's our turn to
eat the story of a Kenyan whistleblower
thank you very much
you